it was a day that started at 8
a.m. until 5 p.m. 5:30 p.m. the moment they
asked me for my passport at the airport
and you told me that I can't
leave syria whenever I want and that
I  go see the police called my
flap for some questions and the game
was to answer a series of
questions who are my friends what are the
activities who are my
political friends named except that the ranks
change every time  at the very end
I arrived in a large office
where there was the gentleman who was
waiting for him who made me moral on
what to do that's what not to
do
me that king  aargau i come from syria
and i am an archaeo-anthropologist at the
ulb anthropology that's what took me
arrived here in europe the scholarship that i have
from the ulb deadlines
for the archaeologist's tribute  khaled el
assad is finally they were
beheaded in palmyra theater
because he made his life for
science unfortunately looking for them  ers
and archaeologists in particular
it was really targeted at me i left
syria to study i
started my training in 2007
when i saw that i was finishing my
studies that
the situation has not always changed in
series I found myself in need
of having some security and at that
time I took the decision with
difficulty to apply for refugee status
and I was recognized as a refugee
in France
I had not had much difficulty
to integrate myself when I arrived in
2007 I had my scholarship there I had my
studies it was my dream to
do archeology anthropology everything was
there for me and after once everything
changed
we locked ourselves in  we don't want to
share anymore we don't want to talk
about syria with a girlfriend anymore we
always said that to continue in this
war of law we built this bubble
it's really soap bubbles
like kids  and that it's very fragile because
we're talking about the  wax and
from the outside for us it's you have to
start over
but
I have this double life since the
war started because I have my
security in terms of professional life
here but at the same time
I have this guilt  to be far from
syria and to think of my parents
every day why me I have this
opportunity to really move forward and that
they live there without really having the
minimum to live on so sometimes it's
really stupid I take  the tram and I
block because for me I can
always take the tram and they
can't take the bus
[Music]